- - Stéphanie Grammont Lucuc
FeFerrandez Haize et Christianan
DuDufour bonsoir..
J'J'accueille Christian depupuis
lolongtemps.s.
MaMais j'accueille Luc Ferrandez
HaHaize dans ce panel.l.
- - Merci à vous.s.
- - On a parlé de la violence ac
MoMonsieur Legault on verra.a.
MaMais on a aussi beaucoup parlé
dede transport avec la mairesseu
REREM de l'Est et il veut apaisr
ceceux qui ont des craintes onon
l'l'écoute et on revient..
- - On a été très clair avecec
ChCharles Émond, le présidentnt
dede la caisse. On veut quee
lala caisse travaille avecec
lala Ville de Montréal, travaile
avavec le gouvernement du Québe.
DoDonc ils ont présenté un proj,
cece projet-là doit être bonifi.
MoMoi, je veux dire à ceux, ente
auautres, qui ont manifesté,é,
quque je vous ai entendus etet
jeje comprends que il y aa
dedes améliorations à apporterr
auau projet de la caisse, puisis
onon va travailler avec la Ville
dede Montréal, avecc
lele gouvernement du Québec.c.
- - Est-ce qu'il y a un tournan?
UnUne prise de position.n.
StStéphanie je commence avec vo,
ilil dit qu'il va serrer la viss
auauprès de la caisse..
IlIl veut qu'il soit plus ouvert
auauprès des commentaires..
- - C'est très agréable d'entene
MoMonsieur Legault dire qu'il ya
dede l'écoute et qu'il a entendu
leles critiques.s.
PaParce que c'est vrai qu'il y n
a a beaucoup..
LeLes gens se préoccupent avec a
prpremière force que s'adonnerer
dadans certains quartiers où
c'c'était vraiment une intégratn
épépouvantable dans des quarties
rérésidentiels..
C'C'est certain que les gens das
leles boissons ils ont raison ds
prpréoccupées et mêmes choses pr
lele centre-ville.e.
LaLa maîtresse avait dit qu'elle
ététait préoccupée mais on nee
sesentait pas qu'il y avait unee
vévéritable écoute..
DaDans la première phase du REMM
dadans la Caisse de dépôt on a u
ququ'ils ont passé pas mal enn
bubulldozer un peu partout..
C'C'est bien d'entendre ça dansa
bobouche premier ministre parcee
quque oui il faut que ça s'intèe
dadans le paysage urbain maiss
c'c'est pas nécessairement unn
trtracé aérien en béton qui cade
dadans ce qu'on a envie d'avoirr
auaujourd'hui en 2021 dans unene
viville comme Montréal..
IlIl y a plein d'autres villeses
cocomme Paris qui ont décidédé
d'd'enfouir les nouvelles statis
dede métro qu'ils ont construit.
PoPourquoi pas ici??
JeJe pense qu'il faut qu'on sese
brbranche que tu..
- - Dans quelle mesure qu'on esà
lala marge??
IlIl y aura peut-être des détais
seseront modifiés.s.
- - Il fait preuve de bonneses
inintentions mais ce qu'il vaa
popouvoir les livrer..
D'D'abord dans les projetsts
réréussis.s.
OnOn considère en premier l'axee
prprojet lui-même mais aussi cee
ququi l'entoure.e.
OuOu on met le résidentiels et à
ququelle distance sont les même.
LLà on a un axe qui fonctionnee
avavec juste l'axe parce qu'ilss
n'n'ont papas de mandat de faire
lala planification du territoir.
OnOn a aussi un projet particulr
paparce qu'il y a de la neige.e.
IlIl y aura des poteaux et sur s
popoteaux la..
C'C'est très différent de tous s
prprojets.s.
- - Je ne comprends pas ce queue
vovous dîtes.s.
VoVous dîtes qu'il n'y aura pase
vivieux films comme dans leses
trtramways..
- - Oui il va y avoir sa dans le
REREM de l'Est..
- - Pardon??
- - Oui parce que tout ce qu'ill
nonous montre ses dérives photos
sasans poteaux mais montrez nous
lilivrer chose..
- - En même temps on a faitit
bebeaucoup de panels, c'est unun
grgrand projet..
C'C'est neuf 10 milliards.s.
- - C'est énorme et puis onn
vovoudrait savoir ce que est-cee
quque ça vaut le coup c'est quoi
lele rapport coût bénéfice danss
totout cela?a?
- - En même temps il y a des ges
ququi étaient contents parce que
popour une fois les projetss
avavancés.s.
- - Oui c'est toujours ça lele
didilemme.e.
OnOn peut se mettre à consulterr
coconsulter mais on saitit
ququ'aujourd'hui c'est trèss
didifficile de mener à terme des
grgros projets parce qu'il y a a
totoujours des problèmes quii
ararrivent..
EnEn même temps il faut armer cs
prprojets-là avec le milieu loc.
J'J'écoutais Stéphanie et luttet
jeje pense au troisième loin dee
QuQuébec..
LeLe rêve est l'équivalent dudu
trtroisième lien et Monsieurr
LeLegault a déjà un problème avc
cece méga projet la Québec..
PoPour l'instant ce sont deses
bebelles paroles..
IlIl faut rester réaliste.e.
MaMais c'est une bonne chose que
lele ton change parce qu'on avat
l'l'impression que le projet étt
pipiloté par des institutions et
l'l'arrimage avec le milieuu
momontréalais était insuffisant.
C'C'est essentiel ce changemente
toton mail va falloir attendre s
gegestes..
- - On avait noté que lors duu
didiscours inaugural de Monsieur
LeLegault le mot Montréal n'avat
papas été prononcé..
OnOn parle maintenant que la vie
fafait partie de l'équation etet
ququ'elle a davantage unee
prpréoccupation politique.e.
- - Oui espérons-le parce quee
c'c'est vrai que pendant lee
didiscours d'ouverture il y avat
unun grand absent et c'était laa
ViVille de Montréal.l.
C'C'est quand même important c't
lala locomotive du Québec et onn
pepeut pas le faire attraction à
cecela..
C'C'est vrai que la taxe n'est s
àà Montréal qu'il faut le plusus
grgrand gain politique, mais ill
fafaut quand même rebâtir less
poponts et je pense que lala
mamaîtresse a aussi ce devoir ls
dede tendre la main et de demanr
auau premier ministre est-ce qun
pepeut travailler ensemble??
EtEt le premier ministre àà
avavantage allait dans ce sens-.
IlIl en va ainsi dans l'intérête
totoute la province.e.
- - Il faut pas oublier que Mmee
PlPlante vient d'être réélu.u.
AvAvec une majorité substantiele
elelle a encore une légitimitété
popolitique par rapport à Monsir
LeLegault.t.
AvAvant on avait l'impression qe
c'c'est une junior par rapport à
lului mais ce n'est plus le cas.
- - Ferrandez soyez-vous unene
didifférence??
- - Oui tout à fait.t.
D'D'abord parce qu'elle-même a é
élélue avec une margee
épépoustouflante d'autres portss
paparce que les os entre deuxx
auautres villes Laval et Longuel
ququi ont des préoccupationsns
sesemblables ils vont pouvoir se
lilier pour aller chercher deses
gagains pour Montréal et saa
rérégion..
OnOn pense au domaine du logemet
dede la sécurité du transport ms
auaussi dans le projet de REM ms
auaussi un axe structurant..
DoDonc il y a des projetss
sesemblables qui vont pouvoir se
dodonner la main et faire un Frt
cocommun et pas faire face àà
QuQuébec mais.....
- - oui je comprends..
SiSi vous étiez avec nous au dét
dede l'émission vous avez vu des
papapillons et des contes pourur
enenfants.
OnOn veut créer des lieux dede
vavaccination très différent.t.
DeDes petits papillons des petis
pepersonnages.s.
OnOn va monter la température pr
papas qu'il fasse.....
IlIl y a des télévisions..
EsEst-ce que c'est ce qu'ill
fafallait faire d'après vousus
StStéphanie pour attirer leses
enenfants mais aussi les parents
dadans ses centres de vaccinatis
ququi vont vrai incessamment??
- - Je pense que c'est sûrementt
trtrès bien mais il y a du travl
àà faire parce que seulement 60%
dedes parents qui ont l'intentin
dede faire vacciner leurs petit.
C'C'est quand même très peu.u.
JeJe pense qu'il faut marteler n
memessage clair et répéter que e
cocomité consultatif nationall
vevendredi à faire son rapport t
a a dit que il fallait fairere
vavacciner les enfants et quee
c'c'était souhaitable parce qu'l
y y a encore des gens qui sese
dedemandent et se questionnent à
jujuste titre de savoir ça vauta
pepeine puisque les enfants nene
sosont pas tant malades.s.
MaMais oui certains problèmess
bebeaucoup et on a vu dess
rereportages sur un jeune quii
s's'était retrouvé dans le métal
apaprès que ce professeur avaitt
ininfecté toute l'école.e.
IlIl y a des enfants qui sont ts
mamalades il y a des écoles quii
feferment à cause de cela..
CeCe sont des dommageses
cocollatéraux.x.
IlIl faut que le message passe l
fafaut qu'on prenne tous leses
momoyens y compris dans less
ququartiers moins favorisés pare
ququ'on sait qu'il y a un écartt
dadans la succès de la vaccinatn
etet si triste de voir que danss
leles quartiers moins favoriséss
leles gens sont moins vaccinés..
IlIl faut faire attention.....
- - ce n'est pas trop en faire e
d'd'élaborer sa aller tout cela?
IlIl faut tenter le tout pour le
totout??
- - Oui absolument..
- - Luc?c?
- - Oui les enfants vont êtree
heheureux.x.
MaMais c'est pas ça qui vava
coconvaincre les enfants d'envor
leles enfants la nation.
LeLes parents qui ont décidé
d'd'envoyer leur enfance vaccinr
sisi ceux qui voulaient déjà se
fafaire vacciner avant le projet
dede vaccinations.
ToTout cela a augmenté en voyant
ququ'il n'y avait pas d'effets
sesecondaires que tout cela se
papassait bien et je pense que
c'c'est ce qui va se passer avec
lala vaccination des enfants.
- - Christian?
- - Je trouve ça délicat la
vavaccination des enfants.
OnOn parlait des travers de la
sasanté qui refusait de vacciner
mmême si leur droit de refuser
CTCTE difficile à comprendre.
MoMoi je comprends très bien les
réréticences de beaucoup de
paparents de voleurs enfants
vavaccinés.
OnOn comprend cela.
CeCe sont des enfants.
LeLes enfants sont sous la
reresponsabilité de parents dont
ilil faut présence tension là-
dededans.
IlIl faut réaliser qu'on est
bebeaucoup dans une idéologie
sasanitaire et je pense que c'et
dede plus en plus le cas.
OnOn est dans le risque zéro.
IlIl faut vraiment faire très
atattention.
MoMoi il y a une idéologie qui
cocommence à me déprimer beaucop
unun espèce de consensus on est
trtrès loin...
OnOn est à des années-lumière de
totout cela ici comme un état
sasanitaire s'installait il faut
s's'y intégrer.
- - Demain ça sera présenté come
ététant la dernière pièce dans e
grgrand plan du retour à la
nonormale en 2022.
BiBientôt même qu'on nous a dit.
- - Oui on a vu des statistiques
papar tranche d'âge et par régin
ilil y avait envie des rondes 10
cocombinaisons où il y avait des
tataux de moins de 50 % et ça va
rerester.
SiSi les enfants sont vaccinés n
a a une couverture mûre à me est
unune des meilleures au monde.
JeJe comprends ce que Christian
didit.
OnOn aurait besoin de plus de
dédébats mais là où il y a
rérésistance à la vaccination ds
d'd'autres pays Hollande Allemae
onon voit que ça ne se passe pas
trtrès bien non plus.
MoMoi je me désole pas qu'on est
sosous cette idéologie sanitaire
popourrait prendre ses mots.
- - Moi je pense que tant mieuxi
leles gens sont parmi les plus
vavacciner ici au Québec et puis
jeje comprends qu'il ne faut pay
alaller en braquant les gens.
CeCe n'est pas une bonne façon y
ararriver.
MaMais oui, prions des vaccinait
etet puis on peut revenir à une
vivie normale rapidement et tout
cecela fait en sorte que oui au
QuQuébec et à Montréal on a eu n
rerebond économique qui a été
imimportant et c'est pas néglig.
IlIl y a des gens souvent quand
l'l'économie va mal.
- - Tour de table, qu'est-ce que
vovous pensez des libéraux qui
didisent que c'est impossible
ququ'il y ait tant d'exception
mémédicale chez les conservateus
ququi n'ont pas été vaccinés.
- - Je trouve que c'est un bon
exexemple de ce que je dénonce.
JeJe trouve ça terrible ce qui e
papasse à Ottawa.
C'C'est un gouvernement qui viet
d'd'être réélu il revient en
chchambre et si de tout ce qu'on
paparle?
EnEn disant que il faudrait cone
vévérifier les rapports des
mémédecins.
JeJe pense que c'est l'exemple e
hahaut on est rendu.
EsEst-ce que c'est de l'intérêt
pupublic?
C'C'est tout ce qu'ils ont à
ofoffrir.
MoMoi ça m'allume.
- - Vous dîtes qu'il y aurait pu
avavoir un autre sujet?
DoDonc que c'est odieux.
- - B ce nouveau gouvernement et
sasa le nouveau priorité c'est e
crcritiquer ceux qui ne sont pas
vavaccinés et demander le rappot
dedes médecins?
- - Les libéraux se sont faits
plplaisir en tapant sur les
coconservateurs et les
coconservateurs ont entendu
l'l'ajout.
ToTous les employés fédéraux ont
eueu l'obligation de vaccinatio.
IlIl fallait que les conservates
acacceptent tout cela.
PaPar ailleurs, il sont aussi
cocontre les cibles de réduction
j'j'ai S et C beaucoup de choses
cocontre lesquelles ils sont das
unune courte période de temps
d'd'ici à Noël.
- - Moi je suis d'accord qu'on
auaurait envie de parler de
d'd'autres choses.
MaMais honnêtement je crois que
leles conservateurs pourraient
momontrer l'exemple et aller se
fafaire vacciner.
JeJe comprends que certains ont
dedes contre-indications médicas
mamais ça devient presque
ététonnant.
- - Congrès de Cuers.
JeJe recevais son porte-parole.
MoMonsieur Nadeau-Dubois.
OnOnt-ils réussi à ramener Cuers
unun peu plus vers le centre
d'd'après vous?
- - Oui parce que d'abord ils st
éléliminés la question de la
grgratuité scolaire 10 qui vont
l'l'atteindre en deux mandats.
SuSur les GES les experts les
prproposaient jusqu'à 75 %.
IlIls ont dit que ils allaient
memettre 55 % comparés à la CAQ
ququi étaient 35 % ils ont voulu
sese placer entre les deux.
JeJe doute de la possibilité
d'd'arriver AU niveau de fluidié
ququi leur permettrait d'atteine
lele pouvoir.
IlIls ont encore très encadré pr
leleurs militants ce qui est trs
imimportant dans un parti de
l'l'opposition puisque c'est un
paparti qui a de la conviction
mamais pour un parti qui veut le
popouvoir c'est un peu plus
didifficile.
- - Moi j'ai l'impression que
cecelui qui a été le plus déçu
c'c'est Gabriel Nadeau-Dubois.
JeJe sais qu'il a dit une chose
didifférente lors de l'entrevue
mamais c'est un type ambitieux t
trtrès intelligent.
IlIl est assez intelligent pour
sasavoir que le Cuers est un pas
dede l'avenir.
EnEn fin de semaine on a constaé
quque la base était fondée dans
mementalement radicales.
EtEt qu'elle ne suivait pas
GaGabriel Nadeau-Dubois.
LoLorsqu'il y a eu des débats sr
lala laïcité et les accusationse
raracisme ont refusé.
C'C'est un vrai problème pour
GaGabriel Nadeau-Dubois puisqu'l
esest conscient qu'il faudrait e
rerecentrer.
LeLe problème c'est que la base
esest très radicale.
- - Si sûre que c'est le test du
réréel qui rattrape Monsieur
NaNadeau-Dubois et ça ne sera ps
évévident puisque si les militas
dédécident qu'il veut aller
jujusqu'à 65 % des gaz à effet e
seserre Monsieur Nadeau-Dubois
réréussit à ramener ça à 55 % ms
çaça demeure bien au-dessus de e
quque la CAQ veut peut-être pas
asassez ambitieux.
IlIl faudrait quand même qu'on
reretire des routes et tous les
vévéhicules haïssant et qu'on
enenlève toute les GES de
l'l'agriculture comment on
ararrivera sa?
C'C'est quand même difficile à
crcroire.
QuQuand les gens vont se rendre
cocompte que ce que ça signifie,
ququ'on va mettre des chiffres